merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse Madame la Ministre de la
censure de la culture pardon dans la
culture
c'est assumé prendre c'est un si
méprendre madame la ministre le 9
février dernier vous avez clairement
menacé de ne pas renouveler les
fréquences de chaîne d'information
privée depuis les studios de média
public ces propos choquants représentent
une atteinte à l'indépendance de leur
comse chargée de réguler la
communication audiovisuelle une atteinte
au pluralisme portée notamment par le
travail des équipes de C8 et cnews suivi
par plus de 11 millions de
téléspectateurs quotidiennement une
menace faite à la liberté d'expression
au débat démocratique madame le ministre
si vos propos portent les valeurs de la
République ce sont celles d'une
république soviétique ou d'une
république bananière dois-je vous
rappeler que nous sommes ici à Paris et
pas à Pyongyang
votre tête à la liberté d'expression au
débat démocratique est aggravé par un
deux poids de mesure car samedi encore
la chaîne publique France 2 incapable
des gars pour les élus d'opposition
accueillis en vedette un tueur en série
sans réaction de l'arcome ni de votre
part vous avez une conception une
application très sélective du rappel du
cadre de la loi C8 collectionne elle
près de 6 millions 700 000 euros
d'amende depuis 6 ans pour 10 ans le non
respect de l'idéologie dominante mais
mon a inter Man et Françoise Laborde
toutes deux anciens membres du CSA
aujourd'hui Arcom n'ont pas manqué de
dénoncer votre insupportable pression
l'essence même de leur com et devrait
être sa totale indépendance vis-à-vis du
pouvoir politique en appelant leur coma
agir vous avez déjà et vous êtes déjà
dans l'ingérence et la pression la
vérité c'est qu'en 2025 nous serons en
deux ans de l'élection présidentielle et
que vous ne supportez plus que
l'opposition puisse s'exprimer sur une
chaîne qui pourtant fait preuve elle
de véritable pluralité en invitant
toutes les opinions toutes les opinions
à s'exprimer alors madame le ministre
alors que le renouvellement des
fréquences de la TNT a lieu en 2025
plutôt que de bravades ou de
fanfaronnade au conclure quelle garantie
pouvez-vous nous apporter pour assurer
le plus ralisme la liberté de
l'information du débat dans
l'audiovisuel français pour vous
répondre la parole est à madame la
ministre de la Culture madame abdull
Malak
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur
sénateur ravier on termine en beauté la
première fois que je vous avais entendu
prononcé mon nom vous aviez défini ma
fonction comme ministre de la déculture
je vois qu'on monte d'un cran je vous
remercie pour cette considération
alors
à chaque fois je rappelle le cadre de la
loi mais ce que j'entends dans ce que
vous venez de dire c'est que vous
contestez au fond les obligations qui
sont posées dans la loi de 86 vous les
contestez visiblement Vous contestez le
fait qu'il faille respecter la dignité
des personnes dans les chaînes de la TNT
qui bénéficient de fréquence gratuite
Vous contestez le fait que on ne peut
pas insulter par exemple un
parlementaire Vous contestez le fait
qu'on ne peut pas
inciter à la haine puisque l'arcom avait
en toute indépendance c'est une décision
de l'art comme
rendu cette décision qui sanctionnait
une des chaînes que vous mentionnez pour
des propos qui en gros
insulter les mineurs étrangers en les
traitant tous de violeurs d'agresseurs
et d'assassins donc vous contestez
finalement la loi si je comprends bien
vous contester le cadre de la loi alors
que je suis ici face à des législateurs
qui sont attachés à cette loi cette loi
qui est le fondement de la démocratie le
fondement de ce qui fait le pluralisme
l'indépendance de l'information dans
notre pays et à laquelle je suis
viscéralement attachée c'est ça la
conclusion et en plus venant de vous
je suis d'autant plus étonnée que vous
défendiez aujourd'hui la liberté de la
presse quand on sait il y a pas si
longtemps que le candidat que vous
défendiez à l'élection présidentielle
faisait huer les journalistes dans ces
meetings et que certains se sont même
fait agresser à ces meetings donc on a
vraiment pas de leçon à recevoir de
votre part respectons la loi rappelons
la loi rien que la loi
[Musique]